a dental work well you know this it can
really be expensive but if your child
also has cancer it's just an
unimaginable burden Roseman University's
College of Dental Medicine has opened a
new Clinic to help families with
children battling cancer and other
life-threatening diseases Candace
Charles live this morning at that new
clinic at Twain and Town Center Drive in
the West Valley Candace good morning to
you
good morning too good morning folks yes
I've hopped in the chair to talk to Dr
Michael cottam about the importance of
making sure your children's teeth are
healthy as it is a childhood dental
health month right so tell us a little
bit about why it's so important it is
childhood dental health month this month
in February and keeping children's teeth
healthy is really important it's one of
the most common reasons but probably the
most common reason that children miss
school it's the most common chronic
childhood disease that there is it's
more common than asthma and any other
kind of infection that you can think of
and just like with any other type of
disease prevention is where it's at you
come to the dentist early when you're
young and we can help get you on the the
right track for good health for the rest
of life and you guys worked with cure
for the kids which is right downstairs
the partnership has been amazing helping
children with cancer and
life-threatening illnesses they really
have to make sure that their teeth are
healthy before they go ahead and get the
treatment why has that been so important
and how is that partnership been
partnership's been fantastic here for
the kids is a wonderful organization and
it's really really helpful to have the
medical side of care and the dental side
of the Care working together for kids
that just have a lot of struggles with
with you know large diseases bleeding
disorders cancer that kind of thing and
it's great support for families
absolutely thank you Dr Adam how are you
doing the community we appreciate you
joining us this early in the morning as
well yes yes so they work together too
they can really get the service done the
same day as they go to care for the kids
and come up here and get the service
done now this treatment facility here is
specifically for children's special
needs well they have another one in
Henderson that also has affordable
prices I was just told you could get
your braces done for half the price you
normally would pay with about seven
thousand dollars to get done for about 3
4 100 there so that's pretty awesome
it's definitely a service you guys
should look into you can go to roseman's
website we'll have those details for you
on the website 8newsnow.com for now live
from Rosen Dental in Summerlin I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now